not quite not quite just give me a say
it says on the screen that it's done
same ones just saying to redirect in Oh
God is come up okay yep okay why good
morning everybody and welcome to the
tores plans committee if you're watching
on youtube or to the members in various
offices and homes welcome to everybody
and I've got a little guide I'm reading
out now for the benefit of everybody for
this virtual meeting I'd like to welcome
all of you to virtual meeting the plans
committee of the 4th of June and I'll
just go through some basic rules for
this meeting so the start of the meeting
will mute all microphones except mine
and please leave all microphones muted
unless you're asked to by me to speak
there'll be the normal public petition
participation item at the start of the
meeting residents who want to exercise
this right have been asked to register
well we've not had anybody register this
morning to speak so there'll be no
members of public speaking
Ward members involved with the
applications have been invited to speak
if they want to indicate that to me that
you'd like to speak or propose or set
into motion please press and raise the
hand symbol because I can see it on the
screen in the participants menu so we've
got that participants participants menu
on your screen press that and that will
flag up that you want to speak these are
shown on my screen in the order that
they are pressed and I'll deal with them
in order giving the appropriate officer
or counselor the opportunity to answer
in between where necessary
I'll also return to the counselor to
check that they're happy with the
response to ensure clarity and accuracy
during the four virtual meetings all
votes will be cast via a verbal recorded
vote and names will be read out in
alphabetical order please state your
vote clearly and slowly when your name
is read out I'm muting and muting your
microphone as necessary
please remember to to ensure full
transparency with the democratic process
this meeting is I've mentioned at the
start is being strained on the council's
YouTube channel we are in unprecedented
times that word again unprecedented and
I ask you all to be patient particularly
with me and during this meeting and to
understand that the processes and advice
may take a bit longer than usual I'll
now ask each committee member to
introduce themselves and Sandel name the
committee member and they'll say who
they are and what Ward Lee represent all
right Sandra Thank You chair council
about councillor Belton I represent
heartland ward councillor Brown
a brand new there seems you've lost
counselor brain
she's not just muted I'm unmuted
I'm counselor Brown from great
Torrington thank you
cancer Christy one thing I did a Stacy
if I could speak as a member of the
public or one of the applications where
on the legal owner of the property there
were no that's correct
nobody's been listed to speak from the
public they see if I could speak as a
member of the public she said yes right
well you Pete can we just finish the
introductions I'll come back to the end
pit counselor Christy
carry on
Thank You chair tensa Craig a I am Ruth
Grady from East cancel unless they
casually Chris leather from northern
northern would cancel unlock comes and
arose me not representing two rivers and
three balls canceling McGough good
morning my name is cancer Thurman golf
and I represent a bit of the North Ward
counselor Watson Watson Brody's cancer
Wiseman Richard Wiseman I represent
these Shabbir and Langtry ward Thank You
counselors right I can I just go back to
councillor Christie because councillor
Christie are you going to absent
yourself from the application or what's
the position made you on that
well yes I I had agreed I wouldn't take
part in the discussion all the votes but
I speak there's either a ward member or
as just a member of the public space II
did clearance said she did say I could
do that
well you yeah you are Yunel I'd like to
do that counsel Chris yes you can speak
and then you have to be muted I think
from the rest of it there's no need for
you to leave
[Music]
as Christie a problem counselors can you
hear yeah okay if we still got counselor
leather
yes am here still yeah okay that's okay
what I was just gonna say Jared that's
okay yes counselor Christy did did email
and asked if that that was okay
and it's absolutely right I just
confirmed that yes he was still entitled
to speak as a member of the public but
he wouldn't take part in the debate or
vote on the application yeah that's fine
that's fine
councillor Christie's happy with that as
well I'm just restoring all the
participants down the left-hand side of
my screen right okay
these are these kind of technical
hitches that I thought we might some of
these things we've got no control of it
right we'll go on now
everybody's been introduced and we'll go
on now to the agenda so we'll go
careful agenda now there we are
the first item is apologies for absence
one on the agenda well there are no
apologies I take it because we're if
everybody's here this morning
Thank You Sandra the next item on the
agenda is the minutes of the meeting
pages 4 to 10 in the agenda if somebody
that if you happy with those minutes
from our last meeting of something like
to propose them out for both councillor
Watson proposing these are the minutes
of the 5th of March
yeah seconder for those now second the
catch the Wiseman second in them can you
all indicate out so it chair that
councillor Christie almost amazing sorry
counselor Christie seconded them can you
all show if you're happy with those
meetings please either hand upon the
screen or there's a thumbs up we can put
okay yeah fine everybody shall be a team
you know chat sorry check could I ask
the democratic services officer to go
around each member individually and
confirm the mission thank you all right
station thank you Thank You chair I'll
read out the names cancel about turn or
answer Brown I was absent for that
meeting
Thank You cancer brain cancer Christie
Oh cancer Cragie cancel a Cragie for
Thank You councillor leather or that's
the lock oh that's lemma golf or cancer
Watson
oh that's the Wiseman abstained Thank
You counselors well that was all in
favor apart from two abstentions was it
yes chair - thank you we move on their
item three on the agenda is the usual
one declarations of interest we've heard
that mentioned at the start with
councillor Christie but members were
interested Eclair should refer to the
agenda item and describe the nature of
their interest when the item is being
considered elected members of Devon
County Council and town and power
councils who have considered a planning
application by virtue of their
membership of that council hold a
personal interest and are deemed to have
considered the arbitration separately
and the expressed views of that council
do not bind the members concerned who
considered the application of fresh and
I always mention here that it's only at
the full council meeting at courage of
the plans committee that all the
information even the last minute
submissions sometime here so that's why
there's a difference between having
considered it elsewhere right we'll move
on to item four on the agenda yeah sorry
counselor Craig II would like to speak
Craig it's now that I'm not sure whether
councilor Craig could put a high yes I
believe that the application number fees
and by the bridge trust and I'm a
trustee on the bridge truss I don't know
what my position is right well that the
applicant yeah do occasion the occasion
the application isn't by the bridge
trust but Stacy if you've got some
advice for councilor grave
just sorry cantilevers just obtained
some clarification from the planning
officers and I think counselor Craigie
you're in the same position as
councillor Christie I understand the
applications made by a tenon of the
bridge trust and but yes as owner of the
property I think you're gonna be in the
same position as councillor Christie in
that you are you can have speak as a
member of the public but won't be able
to take part in the discussion or the
vote on the application okay thank you
no thanks clarification there says it
right um for on the agenda is agreement
between parts volunteer well there is no
part two on this item 5 is urgent
matters I've no urgent matters to bring
forward 6 on the agenda a future site
visits well there are none listed at
present 7 is public participation there
were no speakers of the public but as
we've heard earlier councillor Christie
and councillor cray he will be speaking
on one application as members of the
public but they'll not take part in the
debate of the vote item 8 on the agenda
is the appeal decisions the summary and
also the appeal decisions in there which
the on pages 12 to 67 and I'm not that
the Burwood one there in all its detail
is is there for us if no is anything to
mention on those they just everybody
happy just to note those appeal
decisions chair councillor Christie
would like to speak
thanks like Christie yeah I see his
hands go up yeah thank you
um I actually put my hand up under
urgent matters I'm just gonna ask a
question when is our local plan they're
looking reviewed because we were told
it's going to be annually reviewed
because given the recent discussions
we've had over wind turbines of
affordable homes I think we need to
revisit this fairly quickly that was my
first
second point was under the appeal
decisions
you see we won the appeal some
Morrison's this is simply we won that
but unfortunately since we won that the
government is basically said
supermarkets can ignore that I'm not
strong when our planning rules are going
to come back into place because I have
had complaints from the people living
next to supermarket about these lorries
arriving ever earlier and I'm not sure
when it's going to revert back to the
appeal decision that we won
thank you it Shawn Shawn Ellington you
drop Lancer cosa Christian I believe
that the Blanco plum has started to be
review but if you'd like to answer that
Shawn Thank You council ever fully
benefit only public but maybe Ewing this
committee my neutral mountain and
Council to comment on the first element
of councilor Christie's question the new
local plan as you aware as we discussed
at previous committee meetings we are
looking of my policy colleagues will be
looking future at reviewing elements of
the local plan due to the exceptional
circumstances of coronavirus I believe
the local plan working group has been
postponed to a later date I will of
course get an update for all committee
members and we can be mail-out rounds
from our policy colleagues with any
dates or plans when that may come back
online in relation to the deliveries
you're quite right councillor Christie
we had won the appeal but central
government had also due to coronavirus
sent within I believe it is a written
material statement
comments that we shouldn't be enforcing
against deliveries out of times at
supermarkets understands at the moment I
believe that is only a temporary measure
but as of yet I don't have a date from
such a government wend that may be
relaxed and we will take further
enforcement action thank you thank you
so councillor cragars wants to speak
next comes the crazy thank you it was
just torrington decision i did read it
and it just seems to me very confusing
how can we actually prove that we have a
five-year land supply I mean seems to be
implying that we have to not only have
the land but be able to prove that it
can be developed within the time scale
and that the land is suitable and given
that councillor Christie is always
asking that whether we could do more to
assess the type of land you know given
the Appledore one with they said that
the ground was very difficult to develop
and and we haven't got the resources to
prove that the developments can take
place also it's about employment have we
got the resources to actually prove
whether there's sufficient employment or
unemployment commuting from one one town
to another if if if Shawn would like to
give a brief answer to that councillor
crazy Thank You councillor thank you
casa Craigie
quite difficult to give her brief and
what I would say is that that was the
five thousand on supply and delivery of
housing was the crux of the matter of
the appeal would it's clear that we need
very good evidence and events actually
taking place almost a spading the ground
I would comment that ptosis council and
North Devon Council as a joint local
plan have granted sufficient planning
permissions to meet over and above the
Fabia has announced apply but as
actually the key is their delivery of
those dwellings and that's the difficult
element we have tried to argue and we
had some comfort from developers that a
worker delivered in the time scale
unfortunately in relation to Burwood the
inspector didn't necessarily agree with
us hence the appeal being allowed Thank
You Shawn Council a lot wants to speak
next please
yeah I was just going to make a quick
comment about the fur would appear I did
send a shawl yesterday in the June issue
of Southwest Pharma there was a big
article about planning and they had put
great importance on the bird with the
bill saying you know it was opening the
doors of many landowners and you know
that's a big wood yeah well that's
something we've we feared from that
decision yeah yeah okay we'll move if
everybody's happy with the appeal
decisions then we'll move on to the
costs agenda item 9 which is a cost
decision you see there were two they're
both refused and we move on then to item
10 which is it a GMB decisions all
permitted about from one of them which
was refused let me move on to the
planning applications item 11 and the
first application we have this morning
is application number one oblique zero
to double 7 oblique 2020 a full
application for orchard large Orchard
Hill bid not Biddeford its northern and
recommendation it's an extension to
garden store to include home office and
celery to the main dwelling and the
recommendation from the officer is to
grant and Christian Eva is he planning
office Realty it take us through this
one thanks Chris
thank you sure firstly lovely CEO and
increasingly the public who wouldn't be
aware of who I am and I don't need to go
back over what you said about what the
description is but it would be worth
saying that this applications
being heard committee because the
applicant is related to a member of
stuff I just move on to the next slide a
moment so this is the site location plan
as you see it's a large detached
dwelling accessed of Orchard Hill and if
we go on to the block plan you will see
to the south near the entrance as an
existing Gardens thoughts if I highlight
it here and then there's a proposed
extension there as well if we move on to
next slide here's aerial photography of
the the site you can see Howard Road
roundabout in the top left corner for
those those of you who might not be
aware of where and Orchard Hill is this
is a photograph of the site is just
inside the driveway
looking to the left and that's of the
existing building you can you can see it
clearly here it's green out building
which is a garden store this is a view
from the front of the dwelling from the
highway itself the the garden saw would
be approximately behind the hedge here
as you can see it's it's fairly well
screened I can't really see it these are
the comparison elevations so existing on
your left and proposed on your right so
you can you can see it's extending north
but keeping a similar Ridge and eaves
and utilizing the existing building
where possible this is again
comparison showing existing and proposed
floor plans you can see that there's
still retained garden store however
they're in a home office which I'm sure
be useful for in coronavirus
the main plan considerations shown on
the screen you're seeing it in my
officer report that I've concluded there
aren't any significant impacts and the
principle is acceptable
therefore I'm recommending approval
subjects of four conditions the standard
two conditions relating to three years
time and plans but also an additional
condition relating to the building
remaining is incidental accommodation so
it cannot be used as an annex and also
as the installation of a bird box to
encourage ecological net gain that's my
presentation over and I'll pass back
over to yourself chair thank you Chris
thank you for that and I see console.log
hand up just speak flush to this
counselor lock yeah thank you for that
good presentation the first yeah I mean
northern town council recommend approved
with this application and I see six
neighbors were consulted and there's no
objections received from any of them
there's only that small increase in
height that Chris is mentioned there's
no impact on parking and I'm glad to see
the condition about not being able to be
changed into a dwelling and so I would
recommend approval but I wait to see
what others saying but I think I commend
approval thank you castles a lot
councillor Wiseman so councillor Brian
next next to speak councillor Brown too
I noticed too that there are no
objections and it will be just a
single-story
application no overbearing impacts loss
of lights or privacy I'd like to second
the proposal please Thank You councillor
Brown
councillor Wiseman next to speak Thank
You chair yeah I'm not that familiar
with Orchard Hill so I did go up there
last week and I have a look at the site
and it will be absolutely impossible for
anybody to see it from the road or
probably even the neighbors I'm very
happy I was going to second it but
council Brown going
Thank You councillor Wiseman councillor
Watson Thank You chair I was going to
segment as well I totally agree with
Rosen and the rest of him
I went to look at it on on Google Earth
and yeah I don't find this a problem as
well and I will support the approval
Thank You councillor Watson well I know
this area well Helen I know it's not
it's virtually impossible to see it
without going into the driving ray so
it's been moved for approval and
seconded for approval there's a lot you
move for approval councillor Brown
seconded you having some if you'd like
to read out the members to get the roll
please
Thank You chair Hanson abouten for
canceller Brown for that's a Chris de
whoa that's the Cragie oh thanks little
leather
400x lemma golf or that's the Watson oh
that's the Wiseman oh that's unanimous
chair may be Sandra thank you everybody
we move on now to our next application
there are two applications concerning
this one the next one to follow is a
listed building application but the
first one is one oblique zero one two
one oblique 2020 a full application
retrospective application for the
retention of flat roof covering an
existing well what was an autumn yard
that down is to a bridge and Street
Biddeford and Ryan Ryan's and the
recommendation is to grant and planning
officer Ryan stepa will give us a
presentation on this one thanks Ryan
Thank You chair as already mentioned my
name is Ryan several and I'm a planning
officer choice of counsel and I'm the
case officer for
the application as you've aptly
describes before we proceed I just like
to add that we received a late objection
on the 2nd of June which has been
forwarded to all counselors prior to
this committee has been uploaded to the
council's website as public the first
slide is the location plan and as you
can see the site is shaded in red
towards the eastern part of Bridgeton
Street the application site is a is a
take away and surrounded by similar take
away
slash restaurant uses in that part of
Bridge and Street the building is great
too listed and located the conservation
area for Biddeford and is surrounded by
several listed buildings in fact the
next slide shows the block plan so again
you've got the application site aged in
red and in the hatched area denoting
where the flat roof extension has
located is located the next slide shows
a close-up image of of the new new flat
roof covering the existing yard and this
is a view from within the freezer store
within the extension looking at the
freezer store these are longer distance
images so the one on the left is a view
from pannier pantry to the southeast of
the site and then you've got a view from
bridge trust chambers to the west and
this is a view from the rear of factory
cottage at first floor level again
looking at the extension the new flat
roof which I can saw show you which is
this this this here and again it's a
good image to sort of highlight the the
different roof scapes in part of britain
street this is an arrow image with the
area edged in red denoting the existing
yard which has now been covered by a
flat roof and this is a section drawing
again showing where the flat roof is
located and what it covers it covers the
existing fruit a new freezer saw
this is a floor plan and shaded area
indicates where the flat roof is located
and the main plan considerations are the
principal development character
including the impact on mr. buildings
conservation areas and residential
munity the recommendation for this
application is that it be approved
subject to standard conditions thank you
for your time and if you've got any
questions I'll be more than happy to
answer
Thank You Ryan
councillor Watson yes Jo just afraid to
go back onto the onto the slides it is
done and point out where this factory
factory cottage is please sure thing and
I just find it for you know so factory
cottage I'll use the highlighter
hopefully it'll work yeah he's this one
here and I can show you on the other
slides as well so you should clear that
so this is obviously the view from from
factory cottage yeah and then you can't
quite see it in this picture because
it's sort of behind here and again you
can't see it from the picture on the
right either on the block plan it is
yeah is sorry let me write it's here
that's factory Cottage this doesn't go
all the way across the back of factories
there no no that's all right if before I
bringing parents word Magoffin County on
a golf call this application in
originally before I go to councilor
McGough I think we ought to bring in
counselor Kristi who wants to speak as a
member of the public on this and before
the committee discuss it we ought to
hear from the members of the public and
I know it because council trustees all
have plans committees remember the
committee but he speaks to this as a
member of the public
councillor Christie Peter if you'd like
to speak now and say your piece on it
and then if counselor Craig Lee wants to
speak to it is a member of the public
and then then the committee can carry on
with the discussion then so over to you
Peter Thank You chairman
I should explain this is a British Trust
property and I on chairman of the
British trust you may wonder why the
British trust are objecting to one of
their tenants own applications we have
looked at the least that the applicant
has and it does say they have to comply
with planning regulations
hence this planning application you will
notice if you've read the record the
conservation officer points out this is
conservation areas and listed building
on page 80 she does say in conservation
terms it is considered the proposal
should be resisted now you've seen some
photographs of the structure and
basically just consists of a series of
what I can only call jerry-built shacks
with Ruth pelting stuck on top the roof
LT is already coming away and it does
look quite horrendous actually when the
tenants took on the lease they didn't
need this to operate their business they
may say that business has expanded but
we were slightly surprised and we were
told you know this had to be there
because their business you want to read
the letter from the neighbor there are
some very strong points there but I
won't go into that I've read the
Planning Officers report and I'm
actually quite amazed that they've
agreed to grow on this one because I
well recall and I suspect many of you do
other applications than listed buildings
where for example we have specified they
have to use deli bowl slate rather than
modern asbestos Asli and yet nobody can
see that roof at all
and here we're saying solicited building
but you can put up these shacks at the
back with no problem I know there is a
reference to a previous application in
2009
prominent joining building for a similar
extension with torrid granted I should
point out that benefit Town Council
opposed it at the time and we are
opposing this one again I'm also
chairman of the town council planning
committee I was under the impression
that planning was not based on precedent
and therefore to quote that I found that
slightly odd I would ask you to actually
reject this application and if you are
looking for a reason I think it's
spelled out on page 81 of our agenda
today and I will read it out anybody's
watching us on YouTube it's policy sto
for in our own local plan and it says
development must be appropriate and
sympathetic to its setting in terms of
scale density massing quite layout
appearance fenestration materials and
relationship to buildings and landscape
features in the locality and if you read
that clearly this rules out this
development thank you thanks Kent
councillor Christie councillor Craigie
do you want to speak to this as a member
of the public well I would just like to
agree with everything that councillor
Christie has said I don't think it's
appropriate and if we allow people to go
ahead with things without permission
from either the owners or the learning
department I think they're asking for
trouble
thanks counsel Chris councillor Craigie
sorry of course we don't allow anybody
to go home without planning permission
that's why this is a retrospective
application I'll bring in now counsel
and McGough and then councillor Watson
councillor McGough thank you much mr.
chairman yes I did call this application
in because I was quite surprised with
the policy st1 5 he can serve in
heritage assets and the policy DMO 7
historic environment require a great way
will be given to the desirability of
preserve and enhance a North Evans
historic environment they this to me
goes against the grain so stay with us I
have nothing as biz onus obviously this
seven times and we're in I want to see
any business thrive but it's not in its
a conservation area and I'm so surprised
that they flat roof an extension that
does is it's not in keeping moving the
area so I'm very surprised at the office
he was going to write this application
Thank You Carrie shed got Thank You
councilman golf councillor Watson yeah
Peter could you just quote again the
policy number that you you reference
them I'll be honest I missed it you
can't take part Mary's Peters cause you
want to know the policy number that you
reference to DM o 4 DM o 4 okay
development yeah it was st oh yeah sorry
thanks it comes a lot yeah sto for you
right thank you it's in there really all
in the report there on page 81 I just
wanted to know what a reference of
reference cancer lock all right yeah I
mean I know we can't ask counts of
prints any questions there but surely
we're the Billy Byrd trust not aware of
when the actual extension was bill what
I mean it seems to be the wrong way
around this application and there put
the flat roof on an extension that they
don't know that they've got the mission
for and I know the lease and all that is
a civil matter it's a difficult decision
because there's so many different land
ownerships and boundaries and I know
we've can only consider what's in front
of us if perchance this application was
refused would they have to put any
retrospective application for the actual
shed that's my first question is someone
gonna answer that please
well it's just a roof over the yard as
far as I could make it out council lock
Shawn Shawn
Harrington our development manager wants
to come in Shawn
Thank You capsule ever thank Council
lock just to clarify this is a
retrospective application so that
development has taken place as you've
seen the photographs if we were to
committee members were to look to refuse
the application today then obviously
it's those reason that we'd be looking
at a formal enforcement action for
removal of that that flat roof area so
just to clarify from Council a lot it is
retrospective it has taken place and
also just a thinker members have
clarified it as well but council
Christie did quote policy sto four of
the adopted not an entire local plan
thank you thank you sure anybody else
want to speak on this council my golf
thank you I'll ask mr. chairman the
observation really is there any way we
could stipulate that the flat roof gets
changed to a slate roof to try and keep
more in appearance with the area itself
or my on a wing and a prayer
well I can understand that Sean wants to
come back on that to answer it Sean
Thank You councillor Goff just to
comment that a slate blue font it would
be a pitch roof which would be a
different development to what we've got
here in front of us so I don't feel it's
something that we would be able to
condition or do wireless application it
would be fully app couldn't decide if
they wanted to go down that route and
then apply for pitch they briefed thank
you Thank You Sean well first of you
when I when I saw this I thought well
there's nothing too controversial on
earth on our June plans committee Ramona
looked into this and read it and I read
the delay represent him from Susan
juniper Harry juniper lives at fatty
cottage he had actually written in
earlier back in March I think it was I
got the copies in front of me ninth of
March II don't
well his daughter had written on his
behalf objecting to it and also there
was another objection letter written by
somebody who's in one of the flats close
by makes points about it I got to say
when you look at what's in behind
looking at these photographs now it does
look like a third-world development in
behind there how it's been allowed to
develop like this over the years
goodness only knows but it does look a
right mess I mean the flattery I can
understand the business needing to
expand needing more room I'm surprised
they didn't talk to the owners the
bridge trust before he actually did any
work there and sought permission and
because as far as I understand it you
can't alter a landlord's property
without getting their permission but
they've gone ahead and done this and it
does look an eyesore in there it can't
be the only plus side I suppose you
could say is it can't be seen from
anywhere unless you go in behind there
or if you look out from factory cottage
you can't see they're not dip from real
walk but I am inclined to think that the
applicants the applicants are did the
whole flat roof off and put a nice
pitched slate roof along the whole lot
not just this extension but the rest of
that flat roof that you can see which
covers the larger larger part originally
of that yard that was behind em but I
see councillor Watson came Sherlock and
then Sean wants to come back in so
councillor Watson Thank You chairman
yeah it looks a bit more than just a
roof over a yard to be quite honest when
you look at the other pictures of what
they've done inside to get to the to the
freezer thing but yeah the thing is on
one m1a
there are extractors coming out to these
buildings which I presume they're all
listed great - listed as well it seems
that we're just trying to make an
example of this one and yes I would have
thought as big as the truck then you
know the Biddeford this trust is a
breach trust
as big as they are surely they would
have had more should have more control
of over what people do to their property
you know I mean I wouldn't dream of
wanting to do this and unless I ask my
landlord if I could do it so yeah I'll
just wait and see what Rose said then
and at this moment in time if we refuse
this do we say to these other people
who've got the extractors I'm sorry but
you're gonna have to remove them because
they these are great to Mister buildings
no thanks mr. Wattson councillor lock
better been raining Ryan the office is
handling this Ryan if you'd like to come
in and then I'll take a little hop hi I
just thought it'd be useful if I sort of
explained the context for for how I
reached my decision and my
recommendation obviously the
retrospective extension going in front
of us it's 6:00 amongst various
alterations and flat roof extensions I'm
not sure if a pitched extension would be
appropriate in my opinion in this
instance and I also feel that the
decision will be referenced before in
2000 in 2009 was it and I I agree to
some extent with Council Christy that we
don't go on Preston but we also do need
to make maintain consistent
decision-making at the same time and so
you've got an instance here where you're
looking at a harm from this addition and
whether this extension alone results in
significant impact to that list the
building when you've got the existing
scenario around it I think that's all
I'll say
for the time being thanks Ryan I had
written that word on the page here
consistent I've written it on my page
here listening to the discussion
counselor Locke and then Sean Harrington
yeah I mean Brian's does what I was
going to say was in Sarah Chad was
report I mean it is not she says it is
not considered that any
the subject of this application has any
negative bearing on the stages of mr.
build because I was firmly believe that
the damage has already been done if you
turn to page 81 on the report when DMO
Forrest quoted I think the prints of all
of this policy went out the window was
nothing when nothing else was done it
was better all the other works that have
gone on so I don't think you know I
agree what Brian say as the damage has
been done but we seem to be making an
example of this flat roof thank you
thanks a lot Sean thank you capsule ever
what I just wanted to add was actually a
element of process because I'm aware
that Ryan did mention a late objection
that was received that was went to
members of plans committee yesterday I
believe and was also uploaded to the
public domain but as members have been
discussing letter objection I feel it
probably appropriate and transparent and
the planning process for me to read out
that letter now is tell so you're happy
for me to do that counsel yes carry on
Sean thank you okay so if I start dear
Ryan I'm writing on behalf of my father
Harry juniper who as you know is
extremely distressed about the whole
saga he had received a letter dated 21st
and 5020 regarding a public meeting
raised by assume about Danny's to a
business treat Biddeford and Liva wishes
I was able to speak at the meeting but
naturally wants his voice to be heard he
wrote to you of his concerns which he
delivered by hand for your attention to
a blank house when he was initially
contacted earlier this year he has also
tried to phone you on several occasions
as have I but you're always unavailable
he left a message asking you to visit
his home see for yourself the eyesore
and misery which has been caused to him
because over this construction you have
once and again unavailable and then
coronavirus happened his home a factory
cottage ropewalk has enjoyed no natural
sunlight whatsoever during this glorious
spell of weather that we have
experienced during the lockdown and
adding police situation I love pigeons
yes they are yes these vermin are other
words
a health hazard completely surrounding
his home they are in his yard and on all
his windowsills they were a problem
before that since lack of people usually
locked down along the heat they have
motor Clyde having been attracted by the
food from the takeaways Denise had put
up widest spikes and such to move him on
which has just driven them on to my
father's property he is naturally
against doing the same himself as his
home now Aldi resembles a prison whilst
we appreciate that listen it so isn't a
planning matter it is just another issue
which is being caused by the erection in
this building quite simply put it was
built without planning permission and
should be taken down no ifs or buts if
it is allowed to remain standing then
well do we really need the planning
department I think not it will be
clearly it will clearly be a
free-for-all but yet you don't really
spit out I have been assured by a lovely
lady with whom I spoke a little earlier
and as yet is the only person on the
council there showing compassion at all
and my father's concerns will be
considered our meeting on the 4th of
June Thank You counselor
thank you sure yeah I've got a copy of
that letter I read it through myself
it's not true I think it's not true to
say that no officer because Ryan himself
has been to factory cottage and he's
taken photographs I think I'm correct in
saying from factory cottage is that
correct Ryan you have visited the site
so I have visited and the site from next
door
from from alleys and going in standings
itself but obviously because of the
coronavirus crisis we've had some
limitations in terms of site visits
these images that you see before you I
believe were taken by Sarah chapel prior
to the covert lockdown I would only be
able to access the rear guard and a
factory cottage through a vulnerable
person's house and I felt that it was
not appropriate to make a decision to go
and do a site visit on that basis what
instead I did was sort of looked at the
several images we have from north south
and west elevations and came to a
decision
via discussions with obviously my team
that we could make a judgment on the
application without a specific site
visit to factory cotton factory cottages
garden I do sympathize and greatly with
the with the object too though
thank you and you just ask me ask me
could you just tell me who took the
photographs it was from the first floor
at factory cottage I believe it was Sara
chapel you can see a date in the in the
bottom right of those pictures thinking
21st 2018 so it was it was before the
kovat and crisis and so yeah thanks
thanks ryan council McGough mobster
speak again Thank You mr. chairman
yeah yeah I just wanted to defend their
officer officer step again mr. stemple
obviously when I called this in
originally and I spoke to Ryan on many
occasions about this trying to add some
of my concerns it was very helpful
towards me he tried to arrange a site
visit so I can actually gain access with
him to look at this property
Bobbsey given his present circumstances
we weren't able to do so and I want to
touch on it on the letter obviously the
contact you can't get older drying well
I've had lots of members public always
been able to get through to Ryan and
obviously every office is very busy and
they do get back to you in due time so
you know I didn't really like that
comment so much I think it's more
they're very angry developments gone
through but you know I want to defend
the offices there because you know
sometimes we all were busy live so we
live there's lots of people that we've
got to deal with and Ryan is very
professional and he did try and get me a
site visit when I caught it in and he
spent a lot time with me going over the
process a bit conservation actually
supposed to search as well thank you Tim
thanks for that councilman Gough no
members can see from that photograph
dated to 26th of July 2018 this is the
view from the first floor factory
cottage
what concerns me the flat roof you can
see in from the new looking flat roof
and the wall that's obviously been built
as well there there's no guttering on
that flat roof and it does look to fall
into factory cottages real garden area
to me for the look at that I don't know
which way that roof does form it didn't
know from that photograph certainly
there's no guttering around it um well I
think we've thrashed this around as much
as we can and no one's made a proposal
yet if anybody would like to make any
proposal on this well i'll mira propose
the proposals at the grandness council
lock your showing you want to speak I
was just going to say that it's a very
difficult balance because you know when
everyone comes out the coded virus we do
want to encourage any High Street
businesses I know that's not a planning
consideration but I really do think that
the harms already been done to the disc
buildings of the Heritage Area so I will
second council nethers proposal that
it's recommending Thank You council a
lot it is a different it is a difficult
one because when you look at that in
behind the rest of it all and reading
the report walls have been taken down
some all stone walls apparently in the
back have been so it's changed
immeasurably in the back of those
properties there in that very
constricted area which it is councillor
Watson you'd like to speak again because
I was not doing secondly touch of it
because I know it looks looks an eyesore
but probably looked and I saw there
before that before that was built but
surely we could we can help the
gentleman there about the pigeon
situation through through our offices in
environmental don't we well that's a
separate us nothing to do with a
planning no no you know well I'll take
that up on my own that's what I will
unless yeah unless anybody else would
like to speak on it it's been proposed
and seconded that we do grant this
retrospective application so Sandra
could you go down through the list of
counselors please or missing counselor
Christian counselor Gregor
yes chair counselor Banton at for Kent
LeBron or cancel leather poor that's the
look or that's the McGough against
cancel or Watson oh and cancel Wiseman
or six that vote chair is six for and
one against yeah Thank You Sandra thank
you will now move on then to the listed
building application for this same site
this is application number one oblique
zero one double to 2020 listed building
for the retrospective application at two
a Briton Street damage to abrasion
Street I just like to present this yeah
Thank You chair again much of this
presentation these slides remain the
same so I'll just swiftly moves through
them so obviously you've got the
location planners as previously just
described the block plan the image of
the extension the view of the freezer
store and the longer distance views from
Pioneer pantry and bridge trust chambers
the view from the rear factory cottage
the aerial image section drawing the
floor plan this is where the this
application differs and the main
considerations are the impacts on the
list of building and environmental
considerations and the recommendation is
that the application be approved subject
to standard conditions thank you and any
questions just ask
thank you Thank You Ryan who would like
to speak on this one I mean meet you
cancer Watson yep
yes I'm sorry I was forgot to put me
blue handle all right hello can I carry
on carry on yeah
well are we with just approve the
previous one I find it hard not to be
able to approve this one so I think we
should just have to go with this one
just you know so I propose that we
approve it you recommending approval
then I'm recommending approval because I
can't see I can't see how we can approve
the recent the first one which was a
very very good debate about it and and
it is well it is what it is and yeah I
can't see how we couldn't we can go
against this one okay
Thank You councillor Watson anybody else
wish to speak on this
comes from the Gulf and
Wiseman oh sorry Michelle Thank You mr.
chairman no I disagree with accounts of
what's in there I will be supporting
this from here and I went against the
last one but the decision was to
brighten that one there and just staff
to go against us from there so I'll be
going for this one
you can say McGough council Wiseman yeah
Thank You chair yeah just in the
interests of being rational really and
consistent you know we've we've we've
raised all the issues I think the need
to be raised already so I'm happy to
second that listed building consent
Thank You councillor Wiseman and I would
just say that I suppose on this
application both the one we just
discussed in this one that the owner of
the property probably it's up to them
what they do is their property they must
have some discussions with the tenant
then that's not a planning matter for us
but I agree we've got to be consistent
with this and in the previous one we did
mention a lot of the conservation
aspects to this so it's been proposed by
a Council of Watson to grant this listed
building consent and seconded by
Councillor Wiseman someone if you'd like
to go down the list permitting
councillor Christian counselor Craig a
thank you can't Slobodan for leather or
that's the look or eczema golf or cancel
Watson oh and cancel Wiseman all that's
unanimous chair Thank You Sandra thank
you everybody
well that concludes the actual planning
application so we'll move on to agenda
item 12 now which is the planning
decisions between the 20th of the second
20 and the 21st of May this year
starting on page 89 measles and I'll
just read the page numbers and cancer
lot who's waving at me and not putting a
blue hand oh no I come I did pick the
blue
it's not coming up for some reason there
is them it's alright ice is up now it's
up now Rose comes with a lot you want
you to mention all patients you know I
don't panic everyone is the only one
I've got to mention up all these pages
and it's Nick beacon really but does the
prove that I do read it all through the
bottom proposed change of used carriage
the oaktree carried second industrials a
twinkly the applicant should read J week
worth not with clean no Rick Rath
winkworth wi n KW Orta whose I'm sure is
not bothered because you've got his
blood in for him permission yeah well
spotty canceled a lot councillor Craig
he's got a hand up to speak oh sorry
counselor Christie and then councillor
Craig a counselor crispy chicken so
Christie I think you yes my refers to
the very first one actually on page 89
and where there's number of houses being
developed as a removal of on-site local
area spray yeah Town Council when we
look through this we actually pointed
this out that there's nowhere else on
this development for children to play is
there some sort of break even number
where you have to provide an area of
play and if not why is this development
being allowed to go ahead with this
change change and I'll just bring Shawn
Harrington in on this a minute and
because we aren't we did decide that any
variations of planning planning
conditions came to board members so the
board members that would come under bid
if it says up there so I take it the
board members for Biddeford sales were
notified of this it should have been and
whether they made any comments I don't
know but I bring Sean Harrington in now
on this sure Thank You counsel ever just
to clarify
it was the any no material amendments
would go to ward members as opposed to
variation of conditions or a separate
application thank you
yep in relation to this applications
quite a long outstanding applications
and see who's 2018 it was submitted
there was impacts on the developer area
of the actual site following the
original granted Planning Commission
which resulted in less developer land
being available to make the patient
viable in stat Li time in 2018 it was
considered acceptable that a financial
contribution for public open space was
accepted and that was tied up in their
section 106 agreement as part of this
variation of condition application it's
taking a long time to actually be
permitted because whilst the
considerations were looked at in 2030
2018 it's taking civil time for the
section 106 agreement to be signed with
landowners Thank You councillor Craigie
you wanted to speak and I wanted to
speak on the same item I was just
concerned that we were allowing the
developers to not provide play area with
with the development I couldn't
understand why why can they put in for
something with a condition and then just
ask for the condition to be varied
without was commenting on it well of
course any conditions are applied and
Sean I'll come back in a minute any
conditions that are applied to planning
permission the the applicant can ask for
any of them to be varied if they want
and I'll bring strong and again because
he did explain the reason and they've
made a cash contribution apparently for
off-site provision but Sean thank you
can stir crazy favorite castle ever yes
they come in as a variation of condition
application it is subject to public
consultation the same as a plain
application would do so this one was
advertised it be open for compare for
representations objections etc so it is
something that is in the wider public
domain as a variation of condition and
yeah just clarify it was a financial
contribution announced and it was 25,000
pounds directed to Victoria
it's a strategic open space in the area
thank you sure right I'll move over the
page then on that page 90 and I just
highlighted for myself at the top there
because I don't cancel Christie's
mentioned this in the past the
conversion of formicola factory down
little John's old coal yard at West Kim
they've been granted by planning
permission for that and I'll counselor
Kristie ray has risen raised this with
the possible the wider area development
down there but they've got their
plumbing permission there I've seen and
he has been an eyesore down there for a
long time they all call you don't need
Peter if you want to speak on this I
told you said word on it um well yes I
actually because this would have
benefited both Tories and the developer
I we thought she because that expands
the application that's been agreed here
all the traffic comes straight out onto
probably the worst corner in benefit and
I'm just amazed that highway agreed to
it to be honest if he had gone in with
our site we could have had a much better
development there and obviously it would
help but clearly he didn't want to I'm
still uncertain how they're going to
manage the traffic down there and also
this is the one site I think in the
whole of torrid where the Environment
Agency seemed to have changed their
recommendation over flooding because
this was ruled out for development
because of flooding but suddenly the
bond agency a few years ago it seemed to
change our mind though it's going to be
very interesting to see when this
development actually if it does occur
what's going to happen down there of
course years ago it always surprised me
when Stella Maris got developed that
they didn't insist that big Stonewall
was moved back needn't have been
demolished and done away with but on
that been there
opposite the coal yard they couldn't
they could have taken that wall down and
moved it back but that would have been
extra cost hospitals and made an
improvement to the road there but they
didn't do it but we'll see maybe they
won't go ahead with this development yet
and it might come in later on but will
it would have been a comprehensive
scheme in the area would have been good
but anyway they're there right I'll move
on I think that phase 91 page 92 piece
93 94 95 96 97 98 99 100 101 I mean this
gives everybody an idea anybody watching
on YouTube the amount of applications
because there's a long long list of them
page 102 that have to be dealt with by
the front office page 103 104 105 106
107 and then on the back page underneath
there's some refuses 1 2 3 4 5 accusers
Katherine whether it's some read 3 yeah
Mia gone councillor Watson yeah out of
all those I did see a little blue and
what I did I put a little blue I'm doing
before you ignored me and after all
those all those applications that have
been approved over all that period of
time all we end up is with 5 refusals
which i think is great
that shows that the planning planning
department are actually working for
Norwich and doing a good job that oh
thank you
Thank You Casey Watson right there's no
item 13 excluding the public there's no
clothes part to close session so in
actual fact that is the end of our plans
committee meeting and
that's a nice slide too but thank you
and goodbye especially to all those
who've been watching on YouTube we'll
see if there's any comments come back on
YouTube but once we've come off YouTube
I think if members would like to stay on
and we can have a bit of a wash up and
thank you to everybody
sure larrington wanted to speak Sean
thank council ever yeah I just want to
thank all councillors for participating
in our first virtual committee
I hope all council has found it useful
and members of public swear I hope it
was useful to you Pelias on YouTube
thank you very much thank you if Tom
could tell me that when we are